so I want to start with two facts right
fact number one classical computers have
enabled amazing things the Internet
they're part of how I got here I was
able to fly across the country on a
plane right the electronic giraffe
outside blaring music right classical
computers have been able just amazing
things but one of the things we don't
often talk about is all the things they
can't do right we talk about all this
stuff they can do there's so many things
I can't so I want to start with two
examples of things classical computers
are really bad at and you know maybe
they can solve small versions of these
types of problems but by the time the
problem gets big enough to be
interesting we just run out of computing
horsepower so the first example is
optimization right optimization is I
want to find the best solution to a
problem among many possible solutions
alright so here's a picture of a table
this is a table at my wedding it's one
of many tables but you know you can see
ten people around a table you have ten
people over for dinner how many
different ways are there to configure
ten people around a table all right the
answer is 10 factorial right the number
10 seems so small but 10 factorial is
3.6 million
there's 3.6 million ways to arrange 10
people for dinner right next time you
guys have dinner with 10 friends share
that fun fact with them right so so when
we go and do this we consider some of
the options we make approximations right
because it's the only way we're really
gonna end up seating people at all right
but you know the truth of the matter is
every time I add one person to my dinner
table the number of possible
configurations grows exponentially all
right so we can solve small versions of
this problem on classical machines but
we don't solve big problems big versions
of this problem very well at all second
example is chemistry this is a picture
of a nitrogenase enzyme you know anyone
who's ever eaten food should care about
this enzyme it's an important catalyst
for the creation of ammonia which is an
important component of food fertilizer
pharmaceuticals and many other things so
this is the enzyme I've called out three
molecules iron sulfide clusters in this
enzyme of different sizes the one on the
left it's four iron atoms and four
sulphur atoms believe it or not this is
the biggest of those iron sulfide
clusters we can simulate on the biggest
supercomputer that we have right it's so
small
why is that the biggest molecule of
these three that we can that we can
actually simulate on a classical machine
and the reason is because to actually
simulate what's going on in that
molecule I have to account for every
electron electron repulsion and every
attraction of the electrons of the
nuclei and that number grows
exponentially the bigger the molecule
right every single electron exerts an
electrostatic force on every single
other electron right so when I add
another one I got to recalculate all the
electron energies right so these two
bigger clusters they look so small we
can't simulate them okay so there's
actually many problems that have this
characteristic and what they have in
common is this this idea of exponential
scaling so there's a there's a classic
fable about the power of an exponential
and the fable goes you know the creator
of the game of chess brought the chess
board to the Emperor and the Emperor
said I love this game what can I give
you as a reward right and the craftsman
said okay there's 64 squares on the
chess board on day one
give me one grain of rice and every day
after that double the number of grains
of rice I get right so on the first day
Emperor gives him one grain of rice the
next day to the next day for the next
day eight and after a week he had a
teaspoon full of rice but after a month
he had the rice production of a small
country and after the full 64 squares it
was Mount Everest of rice right so it
grows really fast the number 64 doesn't
sound that big but two to the 64 is an
enormous number so why do we think
quantum computing is actually going to
allow us to solve some of these problems
we can't solve classically right so it
boils down to two fundamentally quantum
effects one of the effects is
superposition so classical information
is basically a string of zeros and ones
you know everything that classical
computing has enabled is you know boiled
down to a sequence of zeros and ones so
quantum computing or quantum information
has this property that the state
can exist in a superposition of 0 and 1
right so not just 0 not just one but a
superposition of 0 and 1 right and you
can also have complex superpositions of
0 and 1 so you start to be able to
explore much richer set of states so if
one cubic can be in a superposition of
two states then two qubits can be in a
superposition of four states and three
qubits can be in a superposition of
eight states so the possibility space
you can explore is much more interesting
and complex in quantum information so
that this the diagram on the right is
showing you a superposition of five
cubits five cubits right so you can be
in a superposition of 32 states so
superposition is the first thing the
second thing is entanglement this idea
of entanglement is okay I've got two
qubits and I'm entangling them together
so measuring the first qubit can tell me
something about what will happen when I
measure the second qubit okay so
entanglement is the second property that
gives quantum information a really
unique difference so together this
allows us to totally change how we run
algorithms right so take the
optimization case if I'm going to
consider three point six million
possible ways of configuring ten people
at a table classically I have to
consider each one individually and then
I have to compare them all right here's
how quantum computing is going to solve
that problem
you take your qubits you go into a
superposition of all the possible states
all the possible configurations and then
when you encode the problem into your
quantum computer you're applying a phase
on each of the states the phase is you
know that kind of access towards the
center of that sphere you saw in the
previous chart
you code a phase on each of the states
and you know when waves are in phase the
amplitudes add and the waves are out of
phase they cancel right so when you have
noise cancelling headphones what you're
doing is you're creating noise that's
exactly out of phase with the noise
you're trying to cancel right so in
quantum computing you're gonna go into a
superposition of all these states when
you encode the problem onto the machine
you're applying a phase on each of the
coupon each of the states and then
you're using interference and you
amplify some answers and you cancel
other answers eventually arrive at the
solution so it's just totally different
right you just got a completely rethink
how we're gonna solve these problems and
that's
it's kind of how Quantum's gonna do it
so it's obvious why the number of qubit
matter keep its matter right if I have
one qubit I can be in two states and the
more qubits I can I can have I can be in
a superposition of two to the end States
but another important factor is this
error rate right I have to be able to
control what's going on in the qubits if
I have really high errors and all of my
operations don't work out as I expect
them to then that's not going to really
work so we're promoting a new metric
called quantum volume where we're saying
okay if you increase the number of
qubits you can get to higher
computational power but not if you have
really high error rates so we have to
both move towards lower error rates and
higher cubic count okay so how do you
actually build a quantum computer right
this is how it should work theoretically
how do you actually go and do this in
real life so first of all you have to
have qubits that work in such a way that
you can harness quantum mechanics so we
build basically artificial atoms
you know atoms behave quantum
mechanically we build an artificial atom
and we make it out of a superconducting
Josephson Junction coupled to a
microwave resonator okay so this is what
it actually looks like on the chip you
have these squares that are your qubits
and these squiggly lines are your
microwave resonators and inside of the
qubit is a superconducting Josephson
Junction and we got to cool this thing
down to point zero one five Kelvin where
zero is absolute zero right room
temperature is 300 this is significantly
colder than outer space and we talked to
the qubits with microwaves so this is
what it actually looks like this is how
we talk to the qubits we have inside of
a dilution refrigerator which you'll see
on the next chart we have all of these
microwave cables that allow you to
actually go and probe the qubits with
microwaves okay and this is what it
looks like in the actual lab so these
giant white cylinders these are our
dilution refrigerators and here you can
see my friend Nick working on one of the
insides of the of the quantum computer
so great that we can actually do this
but did you know you can play with one
for free today any time you want at our
booth when you go home you can go and
you can play with an actual quantum
computer we've hooked up a five
with quantum computer in the lab you
know through those microwave cables up
out of the fridge through the internet
available to you at this website for
free so you go to this website when you
do you're gonna find three different
user guides one is for total beginners
the beginner's guide is no math just
concepts I'm gonna show you
visualizations of how the qubits work
we're gonna walk you through early
examples you know what are the what are
the gates you can use how do they work
what how could you think about them and
then you go into the user guide the user
guide is gonna show you some of the
linear algebra you need to know it's
going to show you how algorithms work
we're gonna give you a suggestion of
five different algorithms you can run
we're gonna show you what sequence of
operations you need to actually
implement that algorithm and then when
you're really interested you're gonna go
into the developer guide this is gonna
take you to our API online it's sequence
of Jupiter notebooks that are with
written Python and you can actually send
batch jobs to the quantum computer free
just go and learn right we're putting it
out there for you to learn this is what
it's gonna look like when you click in
to the composer tab on the previous
chart you know there's three tabs
there's the composer the user guides and
the community I'm gonna talk about each
of those this is what it looks like when
you click composer you're gonna get to
choose do you want to simulate it you
can choose to simulate where you
actually start with like two qubits
instead of five because it's easier to
get started learning with two or you can
simulate up to twenty cubits we have a
simulator up to 20 cubits
but let's click in to the real device so
clicking in this is the interface you're
gonna see this is a picture of the
actual chip that we have in the lab you
can see those five black squares are
five cubits and the squiggly lines again
are those resonators that we talk to the
qubits with those resonators and here
we're giving you some information you
may want to know about the qubits what's
the coherence time coherence time is how
long does my quantum information last
before it gets it gets out of out of
coherence so for us you know we have 50
to 100 microseconds of coherence time
and that matters because it determines
how many different operations can I do
before my I lose my quantum information
okay so now let's create superposition
we talked about superposition let's
create it you drag and drop the
different gates that you
perform their different logic operations
that we show on the right just drag and
drop it on to the graphical user
interface here I've dragged the H gate
which is the Hadamard gate onto the
score the line representing the first
qubit and I've done a measurement and
actually these are results I got this
morning having run a thousand
experiments on the actual quantum
computer this morning and you get
roughly 50/50 0 & 1 right you're in a
superposition of 0 & 1 when you measure
it randomly chooses half the time to
choose a 0 half the time to chooses 1 if
I'm again if I'm in a superposition I 5
our two qubits in superposition then I
have 4 different possible outcomes 0 0 0
1 1 0 1 1 so if I measure it a thousand
times I get a distribution of each of
those possible outcomes and I can create
entanglement this is how you create a
tangle Minh you put your H gate and then
you apply an entanglement gate this is a
C not what it says if I measure the
qubit to be 0 don't do anything if I
measure the qubit to be 1 flip the
second qubit to 1 so this is called a
bell state and this is an entangled pair
of qubits so you guys can actually go in
and create an tangle min on a real
device in our lab in New York through
the internet which i think is pretty
cool ok so now once you get through the
beginners guy that you're really keen
going to the full user guy this is
showing you some of the algorithms that
we are enabling you to learn about
through through the full user guide if
you click into Grover's algorithm you
can get a whole derivation of what's
going on in that algorithm and we show
you this is how you should think about
that quantum interference that amplitude
amplification right and this is the
sequence of gates you need to implement
Grover's algorithm on the real device
and you can go in and you can actually
implement that algorithm on a real
quantum computer so all of this is made
possible by a bunch of really committed
and passionate makers at IBM this is a
drones eye view of some of the members
of the team outside on the lawn in New
York it's a lot of people that put in a
lot of hours to make this available to
all of you for free okay and so what are
people actually doing with it we have
over 45,000 users worldwide this is a
snapshot of some of them
the white dots represent some of the top
universities with the most number of
users in the quantum computer a lot of
universities are using it to teach we
have a teacher at EPFL who is it as part
of this quantum information curriculum
we have a teacher at UT Austin got
teachers all over the world using it and
then we have people just doing really
cool and interesting fun things with it
there's a woman christine moran she's
that dot at the South Pole in between
measurements on the South Pole telescope
she's just playing around with a
chronica Vida which is really cool you
know we had a workshop we telecast a
workshop from our Zurich Lab to South
Africa so at three high schools in South
Africa is having a quantum information
workshop which is really cool and this
is what those people actually look like
we had Chris Harris Christina in the
bottom right at the South Pole this is
the students at the workshop in South
Africa every summer starting last summer
so I guess it's only the second year in
a row the University of Waterloo runs a
quantum information workshop for their
undergraduates there's a woman Emily who
you know she has a YouTube video that
this is I found her on YouTube she's
talking about what it felt like to
actually run the algorithms on a real
quantum piece of quantum hardware the
first time she's been learning about it
in a classroom she actually got to run
it on a real quantum device which you
know she talks about being kind of an
awesome experience or so people are
actually using this thing for research
there's been 17 I think at this point 17
research papers that have been published
where someone validates their algorithm
on an actual quantum device and allowed
people have made games there's a guy who
created a game called quantum
battleships you know you actually
actually run the you actually run the
game on the actual processor so you know
he's got a blog about it he walks you
through how to actually program the game
how he programmed the game you know
I just think that's really cool and
people are having fun right so we had
the third tab that I mentioned was the
community tab so you know in the
community people are asking questions
and people in our research team are
answering them right so how what is a
scenic aide how do I think about that
from a math you have a point of view
what is what you how come when I have
this sequence of gates it doesn't match
between experiment and theory and a lot
of the time you know because not every
gate has perfect accuracy if you apply
too many in a row then the answer starts
to look more randomized because the
errors add up but then you know any
community is made up of people who like
each other and they like to you know
joke around and have a good time so that
you know some of the posts are like
what's your best quantum pun so you know
they suggest a couple of drinks like gin
and tangle man which I love and you know
how do you implement rock-paper-scissors
on a quantum computer you know we all
we've all played rock-paper-scissors
there was a whole long discussion on one
of the community threads how do you
actually implement rock-paper-scissors
on a quantum computer and actually you
know I'm in the slack Channel we're
members of our team you know answer the
questions and it was like a whole
discussion an actual like theoretical
discussion about well what is the best
way to commit rock-paper-scissors so you
know it's just fun you know people
having a good time and as of last week
we put a 16 qubit device online for beta
users so this is you know this is the
most advanced public quantum computer
available anywhere and it's free and if
you want to sign up as a beta user you
can just go in and sign up and you know
we also had an announcement where we
doubled our quantum volume so not only
did we announce 16 qubits we have
another device with double the quantum
volume and there's a picture of Katie in
New York on Times Square and next to
next to one of our quantum computers so
I encourage all of you to visit our
booth we have a booth in building 2 you
can come and learn we have at least two
different demos that explain to you how
does a qubit work we have a gyroscope
you know that's supposed to be able to
show you what it you know what it's how
to think about you know mapping a
gyroscope on do this thing called a
block sphere that you'll learn about in
our beginners guide and we'll show you a
demo of the experience right you can go
in and you've got that five qubit
interface we've got it up
the booths you can drag and drop gates
you can create entanglement in a real
device online and we've actually hooked
up also some LEDs so then you can
actually visualize the results of your
experiments you can run it a bunch of
times and see how that quantum
randomness those that arbitrary
measurement of zero and one if you're in
a superposition how does that actually
look when you run it and you you show
the results with some LEDs so I've shown
you a bunch of stuff that we've made and
what I like is for all of you to go off
and make something you know we've opened
up this quantum computer done it for a
few reasons one of the reasons is we'd
love to know what you want to do with it
what are the things you guys want to do
with it right we encourage all of you to
go off and make something and share what
share your ideas with us and you know
we'd love to hear about it so thank you
all for your attention
[Applause]